اشهر ملوك مصر عرف عنه انه كان ضعيفا
ومشوها بقدم حنفاء طبعا دفن مع حوالي 130
عصا من مختلف الاشكال والتصاميم والتي قيل
انها كانت عصا لمساعدته على المشي لكن
ثلاثه خبراء في تاريخ مصر القديمه كشفوا
ان مثل هذا الاقتراب قد يكون خاطئا بل ان
الملك المصري كان محاربا متمرسا وليس ملكا
ضعيفا مريضا وفق تقرير لصحيفه ديلي ميل
البريطانيه اوضح العلماء ايضا ان العصا
كانت او العصي كانت مجرد علامه للملوك كما
انحناء القدم قد يكون في الواقع قد نتج
اثناء عمليه التحنيط حيث يمكن ان يؤدي وضع
الماده الصمغيه والمضادات او الضمادات
الضيقه الى تشويه شكل القدم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات